bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre en direct sur notre antenne la
séance de questions cribles thématiques
elle est consacré ce matin à
l'afghanistan
l'afghanistan qui fait partie avec la
question des otages et la réforme des
armées et des dossiers chauds qui
attendent le nouveau ministre de la
défense et ancien sénateur gérard
longuet gérard longuet sera d'ailleurs
interpellé ce matin sur le sort des deux
journalistes de france 3 retenus en
afghanistan depuis 14 mois autre sujet
sur lequel gérard longuet aura à
s'expliquer ce matin devant ses anciens
collègues sénateurs
il s'agit de la présence française en
afghanistan
rappelons que depuis le début de
l'intervention internationale
cinquante cinq soldats français sont
morts en afghanistan tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle du sénat très
bonne science à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions cribles
thématiques sur la situation en
afghanistan
l'auteur de la question et le ministre
pour sa réponse disposent chacun de deux
minutes
une réplique d'une durée d'une minute
maximum peut être présentés soit par
l'auteur de la question soit par l'un
des membres de son groupe politique
je vous rappelle que ce débat est
retransmis en direct sur la chaîne
public sénat il sera rediffusé le mardi
8 mars 2011 sur france 3 après
l'émission ce soir ou jamais de frédéric
taddeï
je sais que chacun des orateurs aura à
coeur de respecter son temps de parole
mais avant de céder la parole première
orateurs inscrits pour sa question je
voudrais saluer le ministre de la
défense
notre collègue gérard longuet lui dire
le plaisir que nous la devons à
l'accueillir au au banc du gouvernement
est souhaitée pour l'exercice de la
fonction qui est la sienne
les meilleurs souhaits donc monsieur me
c'est avec grand plaisir que nous vous
accueillons pour la première fois dans
cette fonction ici dans cette maison qui
est aussi la vôtre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue jacques gauthier pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme les
49 pays membres de la force
internationale d'assistance et de
sécurité
la france est présente en afghanistan
dans le cadre de la résolution 1386 du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
avec pour mandat de stabiliser le pays
et de créer les conditions d'une paix
durable
comme le rappelait françois fillon nous
poursuivrons notre stratégie de
sécurisation de reconstruction et de
stabilisation des autorités et de
responsabilisation des autorités
afghanes
cet effort de la communauté
internationale pour sécuriser le pays
former encadrer l'armée la police et
l'administration haga commence à porter
ses fruits
pourtant les médias occidentaux ne parle
que d'attentats de dommages collatéraux
et de soldats tués vous me permettrez
d'ailleurs de saluer le courage de nos
troupes sur place
les médias ne parlent jamais de cette
reconstruction qui se fait vallée par
balles et 2300 ong présentes 300
international 35 française
les médias ne parlent pas non plus de
tout la coopération civilo militaires
françaises ou des prt américains qui
font un énorme travail construction
d'infrastructures réhabilitation
d'écoles de bâtiments administratifs un
terrain de sport à tagab au sud de la
kapisa construction d'un tribunal à
nijrab c'est le symbole de l'état afghan
qui est de retour aides à l'agriculture
et vous savez que c'est un secteur clé
de l'afghanistan où nous multiplions les
aussi les réalisations dans ce domaine
avec la fourniture d'engrais mais aussi
des infrastructures hydrauliques et puis
des stylos de stockage sans lesquels les
afghans ne peuvent pas conserver leurs
produits et ils doivent les brader on ne
parle pas non plus des maîtres cap
ces cliniques temporaires qui permet
d'assurer le suivi médical alors
monsieur le ministre
quand allons-nous on faire réussir à
présenter aux médias
ce volet positif essentiel de
notre action sans lequel il n'y aura pas
d'avenir pour l'afghanistan
la parole pour répondre à jacques
gauthier et à gérard longuet ministre de
la défense et les anciens combattants
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le président mes chats mais
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'allais me tromper lourdement vie
j'allais me tromper lourdement je
voudrais dire à votre collègue jacques
gauthier que son expression est
parfaitement son observation est
légitime et les fortes et elles
recoupent d'ailleurs le point de vue de
tous les observateurs qui constatent sur
le terrain le formidable travail
construit par par les forces mobilisées
au titre de la résolution 13 186 de
l'onu car il s'agit bien d'une action
internationale
je voudrais à cet instant parler de la
france parlait du ministère de défense
puisque vous interroger le ministre
et dire que le chef d'état major et le
service de communication du chef d'état
major de l'armée de nos armées organise
le plus systématiquement la présence des
journalistes qui le souhaitent en
afghanistan en général et naturellement
dans les secteurs dont nous avons la
charge sur robbie et kapissa pour vous
donner des indications quantitatives
il y a en d'une façon constante en
moyenne deux à trois journalistes
français présents sur le terrain l'année
précédente ce sont 64 médias français
différents qui ont pu grâce au service
de communication du cema être présents
sur le site et partager non seulement la
vie de nos soldats mais également
accéder à chacun de leurs interlocuteurs
afghan qu'il souhaitait rencontrer ce
sont au total je crois plus de 200
journalistes qui y ont été présents sur
ce terrain c'est à eux ensuite qu'il
appartient d'opérer un choix je crois
que cette séance de questions cribles
est particulièrement pertinente parce
qu'elle va permettre de montrer qu'au
delà en effet de l'aspect tragique et
malheureusement inéluctable
de la présence de nos forces en
afghanistan il y a un formidable travail
de reconstruction et je crois qu'à
l'occasion de cette séance crible je
pourrais rappeler ce que parfois la
presse home est de faire connaître à ses
lecteurs merci la parole est maintenant
monsieur gautier vous ne souhaitez pas
un jour les remercier mise et la défense
de sa réponse je fais un rêve
moi aussi que les journalistes parlent
de ce qui est positif parle de ce qui
fonctionne même si c'est vrai que ça ne
fait pas la une des journaux en général
d' avance je les en remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean louis carrère pour le groupe
socialiste devait la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre moi je souhaite est que les
journalistes fassent leur métier tout
simplement
s'agissant s'agissant de ce débat on
entre dans le vif du sujet c'est à dire
dans le domaine réservé peut-être même
dans le domaine exclusif du président de
la république
le retour dans l'otan monsieur le
ministre la très grave surdité aux
évolutions du maghreb la faillite de la
politique africaine et surtout surtout
la docilité face aux impératifs de la
politique extérieure des états unis
notamment en afghanistan
voilà ce que je relève alors monsieur le
ministre face au délitement de la
politique extérieure de la france
je n'irai pas par quatre chemins je lis
déjà indiqué ici le 26 septembre 2010 et
encore le 18 janvier dernier
il nous faut aller vers un retrait
progressif négocier et planifié
d'afghanistan et ceci constitue
constitue notre position constante
depuis plusieurs années notre engagement
militaire sous sa forme actuelle dans le
bourbier afghan ne peut pas réussir et
cela malgré le courage et l'esprit de
sacrifice de nos soldats
d'ailleurs
nous ne sommes pas associés à
l'élaboration de notre stratégie
quoi qu'on dise la solution su solutions
il y à monsieur le ministre est
politique et non pas militaire
il faut sortir de cette logique
infernale avant que nous ne soyons
obligés comme tant d'autres naguère
d'abandonner piteusement à leur sort
l'afghanistan
ces enfants les femmes afghanes qui
vivent sous le joug de l'obscurantisme
mais puisque je connais aussi le goût de
certains pour la polémique politicienne
je signale tout de suite que dans la
mesure où nous sommes des gens
responsables nous n'ambitionnons pas que
toutes nos forces puissent être retiré
brutalement du jour au lendemain
nous souhaitons monsieur s'opère une
négociation une planification avec nos
alliés et avec les autorités afghanes
l'idéal serait faux qu'ailleurs que ce
retrait est mal d'une volonté politique
de les conclure ma question monsieur le
ministre sera direct et j'espère que la
réponse en ira de même
est ce que le gouvernement français ait
forcément le président de la république
en train de manger le capital corp ont
que le retrait militaire d'afghanistan
débutera en 2011
pour nous il faut le dire et il faut le
faire monsieur le ministre pour répondre
à l'auteur oui monsieur le sénateur vous
avez évoqué de très nombreux sujets je m
limité à votre seule question
extrêmement précises les dans le cadre
de la résolution très 186 et les troupes
de l'alliance les troupes françaises ont
vocation à rétablir à transférer au
gouvernement afghan il y a eu deux
élections présidentielles il ait eu des
élections légistatives c'est là la lente
et difficile reconstruction d'un état ce
qui me permet entre parenthèses de dire
tout le bonheur que l'on a d'avoir un
état qui tienne la route
je ferme la parenthèse et cela se
traduit par une politique en effet de
transfert de responsabilités aux
et une afghanisation de la sécurité
secteur par secteur un autorités
d'évaluation qu'on appelle le j'anime
c'est un des nombreux acronyme de la
politique de défense en france comme à
l'étranger évalue chaque situation
nous avons pour répondre précisément à
votre question l'ambition de présenter
ce comité dont nous faisons partie
ce qui veut dire très clairement que
nous sommes associés aux décisions les
plus importantes de la conduite des
opérations de paix et de reconstruction
de l'état en afghanistan ce comité dont
nous faisons partie pourra en effet
examiné jeu nous l'espérons profondément
et nous le proposerons la situation de
la région du sureau be en 2011 mais nous
nous sommes là pour nous transférerons
que dans le cadre d'un accord de ce
comité dont l'adn et dont la décision
définitive appartient au président
karzaï est donc à cet instant je puis
vous affirmer que nous avons la volonté
de l'afghanisation que 2011 et la fin
2011 permettrait de saisir ce comité
mais qu'il serait bien imprudent à cet
instant de tirer une conséquence
définitive car nous sommes dans une un
système dialectique ou nos actions
naturellement sont contre battu et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je ne pourrais
pas être à cet instant plus catégorique
sur cette date même si en effet il
correspond au calendrier souhaité et aux
résultats obtenus sur le terrain par
notre armée brièvement monsieur coeur du
monde bref parce que brièvement monsieur
le président moi moi je crois monsieur
le ministre surtout qu' il faut imiter
les américains quand ils font des choses
justes s'agissant de l'afghanistan et du
commandement intégré de l'otan je ne
partage pas l'attitude du gouvernement
français
nous ne partageons pas mais s'agissant
du débat à l'intérieur du pays et du pot
de l'attitude du président obama
nous partageons cette attitude et nous
souhaitons nous socialistes qu'un
véritable débat sur l'afghanistan
viennent au parlement sanctionné par an
vote sur l'opportunité d'une
tienne et que surtout le président ma
république comprenne que l'opinion
publique française née au delà
européenne souhaite que nous quittons le
plus vite que nous quittions le plus
vite ce bourbier afghan et que nous
remplacions que nous substituer à
l'action militaire une action plus
politique
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue michèle demessine pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
des sénateurs du parti de gaulle vous
avez la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le ministre le 24 février
encore un soldat français a été tué en
afghanistan
c'est le 54e bien sûr il faut rendre un
hommage appuyé à nos militaires pour
leur mission difficile sur le terrain
il n'empêche que la douleur des familles
est immense car aucune réponse
convaincante mais appartenait à apporter
à la question cruel qui se posent
mais pourquoi sont ils morts monsieur le
ministre on d'âge après sondage une
majorité de plus en plus avec écrasante
des français affirment leur opposition
croissante à la présence de nos troupes
en afghanistan
le dernier en date celui de l'ifop pour
l'humanité le 23 février indique que 72
% d'entre eux ne trouvent pas n'approuve
pas l'intervention militaire soit 2% de
plus qu'en juillet mais 8% de plus qu'en
nous 2009
même les sympathisants de votre majorité
l'ump affiche désormais à 55 % leur
hostilité à cette guerre
la majorité des sondés ne voient dans
cette aventure militaire ni perspectives
de rétablissement de la paix ni soutien
réel de la population afghane qui payent
le prix fort prise en otage entre les
insurgés talibans et les forces
occidentales à 88% il considère que la
situation sur place est très difficile
que nos militaires y sont exposés et
qu'il y a un vrai risque d'enlisement
le conflit est plus meurtrier que jamais
dix mille morts sur la seule année
dernière dont 700 soldats de l'otan 1200
policiers
deux mille cinq cents civils et 30 mille
blessés dont on ne parle jamais c'est la
guerre la plus longue de notre histoire
elle a du reste maintenant largement
dépasser celle des soviétiques alignée
sur la position américaine le président
de la république
drapé dans ses certitudes de pseudo
amélioration de la situation toujours
démentez par les faits n'a rien d'autre
à nous offrir que leuliette motif
on y restera le temps qu'il faudra à
votre question
s'agissant de la stratégie des
américains sur le plan politique le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle
est fluctuante et peu claire robert
gates n'at-il pas déclaré que son
ambition aujourd'hui se limiterait à
laisser l'afghanistan au moins dans
l'état où les soviétiques l'avait laissé
rien ne se pourra se construire
durablement que jury où le peuple refuse
rejette l'occupation des troupes
étrangères
la france qui a un autre rôle à jouer
devrait commencer à retirer
progressivement son contingent est
augmenté sont son aide civile au
développement monsieur le ministre les
français ne vous suivent plus on n'a pas
le droit de conduire une guerre en
silence c'est à la nation de confirmer
ou d'infirmer la mise en jeu de la vie
de nos soldats dans ce pays
quand allez vous enfin permettre aux
français de se prononcer à commencer par
sa représentation nationale en
organisant à débat public au parlement
sanctionné par un vote on vous répondra
parole et au ministre de la défense
d'anciens combattants et vous n'aurez
que quelques secondes pour une réplique
éventuelles merci monsieur le président
madame de messine je vous remercie pour
le match que vous avez rendu à l'armée
française et à son action et bien
justement parlons-en des résultats
globaux de l'alliance
nous avons la reconstruction d'un état
je ne reviens pas sur les élections je
voudrais simplement dire que la liberté
d'expression est désormais garanti par
près de 700 journaux 110 radio 30
chaînes de télévision je voudrais
insister sur le fait que par exemple cet
état sur construit avec et je me tourne
vers gens vers votre collègue carrère
une prise en considération de la femme
qui n'existait plus nous le savons vince
près de 28% des femmes aux dés des
parlementaires sont des femmes au
parlement afghan et les jeunes filles
sont désormais scolarisés 35% d'entre
elles le sont nous avons sur le plan de
la santé qui est un indicateur de paix
sociale et de sérénité de vie
une chute de la mortalité infantile
particulièrement spectaculaires ainsi
que l'accès aux soins de première
nécessité de la population accès kit
possible pour 85% de la population 8%
seulement en 2001 il y à bien les
éléments de la reconstruction d'une
société et je vous ai pas naturellement
l'accès à l'éducation les
infrastructures réhabiliter le
triplement de la production
d'électricité
naturellement la diffusion est ce un
bien sûrement des communications 30% de
la population est couverte par le
téléphone
cela n'existait pas en rien et
naturellement la france prend une part
toute particulière dans cette
reconstruction
les 54 morts que vous avez évoquées
madame le sénateur peuvent leur famille
peuvent avoir la fierté de considérer
qu'ils ont participé à une oeuvre de
paix à la reconstruction d'un état faire
en sorte que près de 20 millions
d'habitants puisse espérer accéder à un
moment ou un autre au minimum de
sérénité et par exemple faire en sorte
que cette adoption des droits de l'homme
qui est dans la constitution afghane
soit une réalité décliné sur le terrain
nous passons du moyen-âge au siec
actuelle en épousant progressivement des
valeurs qui sont des valeurs de
démocratie et de république
c'est une oeuvre de longue haleine nous
y sommes associés nous prenons notre
part de responsabilité mais les
résultats en terme de société sont
suffisamment significatif pour que
chacun mesure que cet effort porte des
fruits
même s'ils ne portent pas tous les
fruits quelques secondes à domicile je
demandais à chacun de vraiment respecté
son temps y compris au gouvernement
je voudrais simplement dire à monsieur
le ministre que ça fait des années qu'on
nous parle d'amélioration avec des
chiffres est effectivement mais nous
savons aussi qu'il y a très peu de
réalité derrière cécile très peu de
contenu et que un récent rapport
d'ailleurs nous indiquait que s'agissant
de la scolarisation des filles
certaines sont bien à l'école mais elles
n'ont pas de
il n'y a pas de faire du service
éducatif qu'il aurait livré parce qu'il
ya il y a plus du tout de moyens pour
ses écoles la parole est maintenant
notre collègue yves pozzo di borgo pour
le groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
depuis des années notre vision du monde
arabo-musulman a été pris en étau entre
le spectre des régimes autoritaires et
celui du terroriste al-qaïda s'est ainsi
imposé imposé comme le dernier horizon
d'une population opprimée
c'est peut-être ce tropisme erronée qui
nous a conduit les gars conduit des
occidentaux à s'engager en afghanistan
sans perspective de retrait apparente à
l'internationa états unis en irak à la
diabolisation de l'iran qui ne se limite
pas à la personne de mahmoud amadinejad
et pourtant ces derniers mois ont été
marqués par le surgissement sur la scène
internationale d'une véritable opinion
publique arabe de la tunisie la libye et
l'egypte c'est ailleurs on retrouve là
une même jeunesse éduquée mobiliser
connectés à internet d'un trait la
démocratie naissante que part peut-être
mépris les occidentaux n'ont pas
vraiment vu le terrorisme n'a plus ni
siat iv le mouvement pour lui de soutien
tardif de la cnje la révolution libyenne
semble confirmer une évolution de la
position de l'organisation terroriste
on ne saurait dire pour autant que c'est
un signe d'essoufflement du terrorisme
comme une réponse aux attentes de la
jeunesse musulmane alors que les réseaux
restent actifs partout dans le monde
cela pose plusieurs questions relatives
à l'afghanistan peut-on monsieur mise
déjà en partie répondu répondre à mme
demessine peut-on espérer voir
l'émergence d'une véritable opinion
publique en afghanistan qui deviennent
un allié contre terrorisme comment la
france peut-elle suscité accompagner ce
mouvement
et si nous avons vraiment une opinion
publique qui existe est ce que ce sera
le signe de succès et d'autres
éventuellement le signe notre retrait du
théâtre afghan
voilà gilles respecter mon temps merci
monsieur pozzo di borgo pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur gérard
longuet ministre de la défense vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre
bien monsieur sénateurs cher yves pozzo
di borgo les questions vous avez posées
sont absolument fondamentales ou au
coeur de la reconstruction d'un état
il y à ce qu'europe ce qui répond à 7 et
à l'évolution d'une société il et j'ai
eu le privilège grâce à l'initiative du
président larcher de me rendre sur place
avec les présidents de groupe et avec le
sénateur gauthier d'ailleurs nous avons
bien mesurer l'extraordinaire diversité
de ce pays son caractère compartimentée
qui facilite la poursuite d'organisation
traditionnels dont on peut se dire
qu'elle revêt un caractère assez
hermétique à ce que sont les valeurs et
les mécanismes d'une grande démocratie
moderne que vous appelez de vos voeux et
dont le caractère inéluctable et
profondément souhaité par les uns et par
les autres mais un rythme que nous ne
maîtrisons pas le préalable à la
démocratie c'est les changes
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la liberté de
la presse j'évoquais la communication
j'évoquais les télécommunications
devrait évoquer les transports
lorsqu'une population peut échanger
lorsqu'une population peut comparer
lorsqu'une population peut commercer
elle se libère de l'emprise de système
qui n'est pas complètement d agressif de
traiter de féodaux de traditionnels ou
de clanique et c'est l'idée de cette
circulation de l'information des biens
des services des personnes que seuls
d'ailleurs le maintien de l'ordre peut
garantir qui peut faire bouger sur long
terme
cette société c'est l'objectif de notre
présence c'est un but ambitieux je dois
reconnaître que c'est un but qui est
l'on a construit cieux pozzo di borgo
si elle
le ministre pour l'intelligence de sa
réponse et la clarté des choses c'est
vrai que je n'ai qu'à me rappeler qu'on
a quand même pour aller dans son sens
les élections présidentielles de 2009 et
il s'agit de septembre 2010
nous avons eu quand même 30 à 40% de
participation et malgré les 150 bureaux
de vote attaqués
il est 22 morts le 18 septembre 2010 en
santé qu'une opinion publique avait
commencé à exister
je crois que c'est quand même important
et sur l'assemblée nationale galles je
crois que le passé le chiffre je vous le
rappelle qu' à 10 259 sièges il ya quand
même 68 femmes qui sont présentes dans
ce corps électoral voilà donc ces genres
est un peu dans votre sens de vous
remercier de ce ministre mais c'est vrai
que c'est un rêve qu'on que l'on que
nous avons d'avoir une opinion publique
forte à l'afghanistan
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean pierre chevènement pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole où chaque
collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
président afghan monsieur hamid karzaï
va annoncer le 21 mars dans trois
semaines
quand et où l'armée afghane va prendre
le relais des troupes internationales
il est souhaitable que soient concernés
d'emblée le district de surobi où selon
votre prédécesseur monsieur alain juppé
s'exprimant devant la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
la sécurité était rétablie par les
troupes françaises au courage et au
stoïcisme desquels je veux rendre
hommage
la grande bretagne a annoncé son retrait
au plus tard en 2014
le président sarkozy quant à lui a
déclaré que nous mettions pas lié par
ces délais que nous serions là dans la
durée une formulation aussi général est
elle bien raisonnable dès lors que le
principe de retrait a été posée par la
conférence de lisbonne
la décision vous l'avez rappelé dépend
d'un organisme le jany ben jones afghane
nato inti colborne int equal ça veut
dire transition en pachtoune qui réunit
les responsables afghans de la sécurité
et le commandement de l'alliance
en dernier ressort c'est le président
karzaï qui tranchera nous sommes
représentés dans ce j'anime depuis peu
par notre ambassadeur mais une prise de
position officielle à votre niveau
monsieur le ministre il contribuerait
puisque je le répète les conditions de
l'afghanisation dans le district de
surobi sont réunies et que
l'afghanisation va commencer dans une
vingtaine de jours
or je crois comprendre de vos propos que
la fin de 2011
vous conviendrez tout aussi bien vous
vanter les réalisations sur le terrain
mais monsieur le ministre je crois rêver
j'ai connu la faim de l'algérie
française
j'ai l'impression que nous sommes en
1961 62
quand je vous écoute votre question
ma question la voie là puisque la
transition est désormais irréversible
n'est-il pas préférable de définir avec
l'ensemble nos alliés
un calendrier harmonisé de retrait
pourront certes comporter des
flexibilités mais permettant de
commencer à diminuer sans tarder nos
effectifs engagés
deuxième question ne serait-il pas
opportun d'associer la france au
processus de la transition et donc aux
contacts qui seront pris dans le cas
d'une éventuelle réconciliation
qu'en est il à cet égard de notre
politique vis-à-vis du pakistan dont il
serait utile de connaître les intentions
en vue de faciliter cette transition est
de permettre cette réconciliation des
différentes factions pachtoune
dès lors qu'elle se serait bien entendu
clairement dissocié de l'entreprise du
tourisme international d'al qaïda voilà
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
nos troupes ne doivent pas être
embarqués embedded comme disent les
américains
c'est un processus sur lequel nous
n'aurions aucun contrôle vous avez
consommé un peu votre droit de réplique
monsieur le ministre pour répondre
monsieur chevènement
oui merci monsieur le président
cherchant bien je vainement là une
différence il y a un projet politique ce
projet politique et de transmettre un
état afghan à une structure afghane à
une armée afghane à une police afghane
la responsabilité de gérer un grand pays
qui a une très longue histoire mais qui
n'est assurément pas une société moderne
au sens où le son les démocraties
d'aujourd'hui l'intervention de yves
pozzo di borgo nous rappelait bien qu'il
ne s'agisse pas du monde arabe mais en
l'occurrence du monde musulman une
immense un immense changement qui
bouscule des idées commun et notamment
le sentiment que c'était un monde à part
hermétique aux idées de liberté de
responsabilité individuelle de
démocratie et qui au fond était condamné
à errer à hésiter à vous pardon pas
hésité mais condamnés à choisir entre
des démocrates des autres régimes
autoritaires plus ou moins laïque ou
laïcisant herry et ou au contraire des
régime islamique nous vous avons quelque
chose de nouveau
dont nous savons pas ce qu'il sortira en
ce qui concerne l'afghanistan
nous essayons dé faire évoluer une
société en créant une structure d'état
très concrètement pour le secteur de
surobi
nous allons en effet pour pensons
pouvoir saisir le jeanne yb pour obtenir
une décision du président karzaï et
pouvoir en effet passer la main pour la
kapissa
les efforts sont en cours le calendrier
ne sera absolument pas le même la
différence profonde c'est que lorsque
nous avons transmis la responsabilité
nous devenons libre de nos moyens et je
n'imagine pas un seul instant que le
gouvernement ne propose pas un moment ou
un autre
un débat public est notable et d'abord
au parlement sur la façon dont
évolueront nos engagements lorsque nous
aurons fait notre travail est transmis
la main à la responsabilité afghane car
c'est bien là le projet politique de
l'alliance internationale faire émerger
un état
nous sommes loin des ambiguïtés que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure et qui ont
attristé
des pages de notre histoire sur le
ministre quelques secondes
un seul mot monsieur ministre pour dire
qu' il faudrait redéployer nos moyens
vers une présence civile conformément
une belle et grande tradition de la
france 1 je pense lycée sens culturel
hôpitaux musée fouilles archéologiques
coopération universitaire et
scientifique il vrai que ce retrait de
nos forces
rapide débouche sur un retour de la
france dans des domaines où étaient
traditionnellement présentes on voit
l'inde et la chine multiplié leurs
investissements et elles vont se
disputer le territoire dès lors que les
occidentaux leur ont quittés mais nous
la france nous devons rester présent la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
andré du lait pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole en ouverture le
président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
chacun de nous en mettre conscient le
livre blanc sur la défense nationale et
la sécurité a profondément modifié le
fonctionnement du ministère de la
défense qui en est à sa deuxième réforme
les restructurations qui ont été
conduites avec un but principal celui de
mettre au centre du dispositif
l'homme c'est essentiel à un moment où
nos troupes sont engagés dans un conflit
qui n'est pas qualifié de guerre avec
notre présence en afghanistan la société
redécouvrent la notion du sacrifice
suprême et les blessés de l'hôpital
percy peuvent en témoigner
certes ceux qui reviendront
d'afghanistan auront participé à des
opérations de sécurité et nos mains une
guerre toutefois un certain nombre de
nos concitoyens ont évoqué la
possibilité de commémoration ayant été
le rapporteur du projet de loi sur la
reconversion des militaires
je pense que celle ci doit s'accompagner
d'une nécessaire reconnaissance de la
nation le conflit en afghanistan
sa spécificité doit être appréhendée
sous un volet mémorielle contribuant
ainsi à resserrer le lien armée nation
à l'heure du turn over que connaît
l'armée il s'agit de la place
qu'occupera le futur ex soldat dans la
société après son passage dans
l'institution de la défense mais
également question des rapports de
l'armée avec ce qu'elle a formés et
qu'ils ont quittée transformer aussi
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
savoir quels sont les réflexions menées
par vous même et votre ministère sur ce
point monsieur ministre pour répondre à
monsieur du lait oui monsieur le
président cher andré dulait votre
question est d'une pertinence total je
crois que depuis vingt ans plus de deux
cent mille soldats français ont été
engagés dans des opex de nature
extrêmement différentes
ce qui me conduit sur ce point précis à
vous indiquer que le ministère s'est
mobilisée envoyé un questionnaire à à
plus de 5000 militaires de tous grades
pour s'efforcer de comprendre la façon
dont chacun des participants à ces opex
sur les vingt dernières années ont réagi
et souhaite au fond comment il souhaite
que cette qu'une reconnaissance
nationale leur soit accordée avant même
d'attendre le résultat de cette de cette
étude d'opinion qui débouchera sur des
propositions
le gouvernement a accepté le bénéfice de
la campagne double pour ceux de nos
militaires qui sont engagés à cet
instant en afghanistan aurait évoqué des
points que vous avez est implicitement
évoqué le premier c'est celui des
familles de nos de nos disparus
les soutiens matériels sont solides
les procédures sont complexes mon
prédécesseur et ses collaborateurs ont
préparé un plan pour modifier facilité
et faire en sorte que les familles n'est
pas à se battre dans une sorte de
dédales administratifs qui peut dans
certains cas revêtir un caractère
kafkaïen le deuxième point implicite que
vous avez évoqué c'est celui du statut
de nos blessés vous avez parlé de persil
en effet les mines sont particulièrement
meurtrières implique des reconversions
des réorientations à l'intérieur de
l'armée ou à l'extérieur de l'armée et
de ce point de vue le ministère se
mobilise pour apporter des solutions de
bon sens et de suivi individualisé
nous sommes en mesure de le faire et je
crois que c'est le devoir et l'honneur
j'ajoute que c'est la tradition de notre
armée fut du et merci monsieur ministre
où il se tient à remercier le ministre
pour tous les éléments de réponse qui il
m'a apporté
je crois qu effectivement la
commémoration de tous ces hommes qui
sont soit diminuée physiquement à
l'issue des conflits soient qui
malheureusement perdu la vie la nation
leur doit une reconnaissance et je me
félicite de voir que vous êtes en bonne
voie sur cette démarche
merci la parole est maintenant président
jean pierre bel pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je veux essayer de dire les choses
simplement en afghanistan l'enjeu c'est
la guerre ou la paix en afghanistan
l'enjeu c'est la stabilité d'une région
traversée par des tensions de toute
nature l'enjeu c'est le rôle de la
france et de l'europe dans les relations
internationales
c'est pourquoi bien évidemment nous
devons aborder ce dossier
brûlant et sensible avec gravité esprit
de responsabilité sur le ministre nos
collègues jean louis carrère michelle
demessine jean pierre chevènement ont
posé une question de fond sur le
tragique conflit qui déchire
l'afghanistan et sur notre engagement
dans ces combats
il faut bien sûr d'abord éviter les
malentendus ou les mauvais procès et
c'est un point qui je crois fait
largement consensus
ce point c'est la nécessité de nous
donner les moyens tous les moyens pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
international
on a bien compris que l'objectif c'est
de lutter contre les terroristes
là où ils se trouvent et avec des moyens
appropriés et je voudrais mettre ce
matin un éclairage sur ce qu'il faut
bien appeler un angle mort de notre
action je veux parler de la prise en
compte de la dimension régionale et
notamment du pakistan dans le cadre de
la stratégie en cours en effet ce que
nous avons pu constater dans un voyage
où d'ailleurs nous étions ensemble dans
le cadre d'une mission sénatoriale
diligentée par monsieur le président
larcher
les informations que nous détenons
également démontre que d'une part les
taliban recrutent localement et d'autre
part peuvent compter sur le soutien de
forces venues du pakistan ce fut là
semble loin de se tarir
mais vous avez peut-être d'autres
informations que vous souhaiterez
communiqué au sénat dans ce contexte les
opérations menées par les états unis sur
le territoire pakistanais soulève de
nombreuses interrogations
d'où mes questions que j'espère simples
dans leur annoncer mais ô combien
complexe bien sûr dans leur implication
la france participe tél aux côtés des
etats-unis aux opérations dans les zones
tribales qui sert de sanctuaire aux
talibans afghans et à al-qaïda
sommes-nous associés et si oui de quelle
manière aux décisions qui conduisent à
des frappes militaires sur la zone
frontalière pakistanaise
avons nous des échanges diplomatiques
avec le pakistan sur cette question est
comment entendons-nous réagir pour
obtenir une clarification de la position
du pakistan dont nous avions tous
reconnu que pour le moins elle était
ambigu je vous remercie pour répondre
aux questions du président bayle la
parole et à me suis ministre de la
défense
oui je voudrais monsieur le président
répondre au président bayle le remercier
d'avoir évoqué le déplacement que vous
aviez organisé en afghanistan à kaboul
il y a maintenant presque 18 mois et
dire que ce déplacement m'a permis
peut-être d'apprendre un peu plus rapide
dans ce dossier majeur du ministère que
j'ai l'honneur d'assumer à cet instant
je lui dis de façon catégorique à jean
pierre bel
l'armée française directement ou
indirectement intervient à au pakistan
d'autres peut-être le fond vous avez
évoqué des hypothèses l'armée française
non c'est l'afghanistan c'est
l'application de la résolution 386 des
nations unies et nous ne sortons pas des
territoires dont nous avons le mandat
qu'ils sont à l'est de kaboul
mais qui sont très clairement à
l'intérieur du pakistan
en revanche là où vous avez mille fois
raison c'est que nous avons le devoir
sur le plan diplomatique mais la
responsabilité appartient cet instant à
mon collègue alain juppé de faire en
sorte que le pakistan trouve des
relations apaisées avec la communauté
internationale compte tenu des
inquiétudes et des conflits qui sont les
siens et sur lequel je me garderai bien
de porter un jugement mais dont nous
savons qu'il complique
la sérénité du continent du sous
continent indien
puisqu'il y à des conflits majeurs
connus entre le pakistan et son grand
voisin et qu'à un moment ou un autre on
peut imaginer en effet que les décisions
du pakistan en ce qui concerne son
voisin de l'ouest puissent être
conditionnée par les inquiétudes qu'il
ressent à l'est et donc le débat
international est au coeur du sujet et
l'afghanistan est un élément d'un
système complexe il y à la société
afghane dont j'ai parlé en répondant
mais il ya la situation de l'afghanistan
dont nous savons d'ailleurs que dans
l'histoire indienne
elle a été la base de départ des
dynastie moghole qui ont contrôlé l'inde
s'est donc de l'extérieur des pays
différents
lorsqu'on les connaît vous avez raison
de dire que c'est une réflexion
diplomatiques d'ensemble qui est sous
l'autorité du président et dans le
ministre des affaires étrangères a la
responsabilité
c'est donc lui que vous devriez
interroger à cet instant merci monsieur
le ministre a parlé maintenant notre
collègue didier boulaud et au pardon
excusez moi parce que je je surveille le
temps bien sûr merci monsieur le
président tout le monde les experts les
analystes les diplomates les militaires
aussi s'accordent à reconnaître
aujourd'hui qu'une victoire militaire en
afghanistan est impossible
la france est aujourd'hui dans une
situation délicate de part sa stratégie
dans l'otan je pense que cela nous
interdit de définir nos propres
objectifs stratégiques
c'est pourquoi cela a été dit nous
demandons une nouvelle fois un débat
avec vote du parlement sur l'engagement
militaire en afghanistan
le courage de sens du devoir de nos
soldats sur place ne change rien un
constat de fait notre stratégie
aujourd'hui est insuffisante et ne peut
aboutir il faut en conséquence nous
engager sur un calendrier précis
comportant l'annoncé d'un retrait
progressif
les planifier concertée avec nos alliés
et avec nos partenaires européens et
avec des autorités afghanes
tel est le sens de nos interventions
aujourd'hui je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à notre collègue cette fois ci
didier boulaud pour le groupe socialiste
est la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur milices mama question
portera également sur la communication
publique de la mission française dans le
cadre de la fia ce en afghanistan comme
cela a été évoqué par notre collègue
gauthier ou lui avait apporté un certain
nombre de réponses mais malheureusement
vous nous avez pas convaincu
quand on veut communiquer on trouve les
moyens pour communiquer le savez vous
par exemple monsieur le ministre que
tous les mois le général français qui
commande
nos troupes en afghanistan est invité ou
plus exactement convoqué par le
pentagone a rencontré ou à s'entretenir
avec les journalistes américains savez
vous monsieur le ministre que tous les
trois mois
le gouvernement canadien remet à tous
les parlementaires un rapport public de
plusieurs dizaines de pages parfois même
de plusieurs centaines de pages moi je
pense le ministre que le problème de la
communication il est trop facile d'en
faire porter la responsabilité à la
presse c'est d'ailleurs à ce sujet je
voudrais rendre hommage et avoir une
pensée toute particulière pour les deux
journalistes français retenus encore en
afghanistan au bout de quatre cent
trente jours je crois 429 me semble-t-il
pour être très précis
mon sentiment par rapport à la
communication de ce qui se passe en
afghanistan je pense que c'est le reflet
de l'attitude du gouvernement et en
particulier du président de la
république sur ce qui se passe en
afghanistan nous avons pu constater au
fil des mois et des années
la difficulté à obtenir des débats quand
bien même nous en parlons aujourd'hui la
difficulté à obtenir des votes
à la différence de ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays aux usa en allemagne en
grande-bretagne
où n'existe ni la peur d'affronter la
presse ni la crainte face aux critiques
parlementaire moi je pense que
aujourd'hui la grande muette est muette
parce qu'elle en a reçu l'instruction et
nous vous demandons de libérer les
moyens d'information en particulier de
la dicod auprès de la presse de manière
à ce que celle ci puisse faire son
travail dans de meilleures conditions
et puis je voudrais vous poser une toute
petite question même si je mens piette
sur mon temps de parole du suivant
monsieur le président dans le cadre du
plan de relance et ça concerne
l'afghanistan cinq hélicoptères caracal
ont été financés or nous avons appris
que l'un de ses hélicoptères caracal au
lieu d'être attribuées à l'armée de
l'air étaient destinés à l'exportation
pensez vous monsieur le ministre que
c'est le moment d'exporter des
hélicoptères dont nous avons le plus
grand besoin sur le théâtre et en
particulier en afghanistan
pouvez vous nous confirmer que ce
caracalla été vendus à l'export ou qu'il
reste bien maintenue à destination de
l'afghanistan
la parole est à monsieur gérard longuet
ministre de la défense des anciens
combattants vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre
oui je d'abord vous avez eu raison
le sénateur d'évoquer nos deux
journalistes de france 3 bloqué depuis
décembre 2009 dans l'exercice de leurs
missions
l'armée française avait tout fait pour
qu'ils soient en mesure d'exercer leurs
missions bénéficier de ce soutien
ils ont souhaité aller au delà
avec beaucoup de courage et aujourd'hui
ils en sont très clairement les victimes
c'est la raison pour laquelle m'incliner
vers les journalistes qui font l'effort
de venir en afghanistan d'essayer de
comprendre d'essayer d'expliquer
j'ajoute que toutes les semaines la
direction de la communication demi c'est
la défense qui est un haut fonctionnaire
permanente ce ministère est à la
disposition des journalistes dans un
point presse où il explique très
clairement la situation des opérations
sur le terrain et répond à l'ensemble
des questions qui lui sont posées donc
je pense que très honnêtement l'armée
fait son travail d'information sur la
mission qu'elle assume pour le compte de
la fia ce pour le compte de la
communauté internationale sur le point
très précis que vous nous posez en ce
qui concerne les caracal déployés en
afghanistan
le reconnaître que je ne suis pas encore
extraordinairement familier avec ce
sujet mais s'il y avait eu en effet un
moment une perspectives d'exportation
sur un appareil
manifestement cela n'est pas possible
enfin cela n'a pas été suivi d'effet
parce que la priorité pour le matériel
c'est en effet le théâtre des opérations
la disponibilité dont je dois pouvoir
vous dire très clairement que ce risque
que vous avez évoqué n'est pas confirmée
monsieur boulot n'ont pas de point
particulier me chers collègues nous
allons maintenant clore ce débat en
remerciant ministre remerciant de
collègues et bien sûr nous avons tous eu
une pensée pour nos troupes mais je
voudrais puisqu'on a évoqué la situation
de deux otages journalistes penser à
tous les otages qui sont aujourd'hui
retenu en afrique et ailleurs et je
crois que c'était l'occasion de nous en
souvenir tous collectivement
mes chers collègues
nous allons maintenant suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 14 heures 30
et se poursuivra ce soir pour la suite
de l'examen du projet de loi relatif à
la garde à vue
la séance est donc suspendu c'est la fin
de ces questions cribles thématiques
consacrées à la situation en afghanistan
si vous souhaitez les revoir elles sont
disponibles en vod sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec la séance cet
après-midi 15 heures avec l examen du
projet de loi de réforme de la garde à
vue
bonne journée à tous sur public sénat
il avait demandé à devenir marquer pour
se protéger de la sauvagerie du fln
plutôt eu de séquelles jeudi c'est elle